[Music]  you have information information I need  to have will not tell you anything  don't play games you know exactly what I  want to know and you're going to tell me  what do you want to know  I will put these on your nipples really  yes  can you do that you like that that's so  we do that no no does this would not own  oh I'm not gonna know without getting  we're not doing now what that  information you are going to tell me I  can't it's a state secret I want to know  the address of gal gadot I can't I want  to visit her and say hello kill me kill  me I won't kill you I'll do something  worse I'm gonna sing hava nagila the way  an Irish man same tell me no I'm gonna  do it oh don't do that  [Music]  I knew you'd break you're ashamed to all  of Israel now get out of here  [Music]  you